okay so you're here for this talk how I
learned to time travel or data
pipelining and scheduling with airflow
my name is Laura Lorenz here are some
places you can contact me via the
internet and I'm here actually right now
representing industry dive work that I
do and my job there we're hiring you can
see the little bubble here so if you
want to check us out we're a business
media publishing company it's pretty
cool I would say and if you would like
any other stuff that I'm talking about
right now definitely come talk to me if
you are in the job market so first thing
I want to just put out some truths that
I think we can all get behind one data
is weird and break stuff and user data
is particularly untrustworthy just don't
trust it so we deal our whole ETL
process that we've been developing at
industry dive has been a lot related to
user data that they submit so we've had
a lot of exciting times with that and
other one is that computers slash the
internet slash third-party services
slash everything will fail and blow up
all of the scripts that you wrote to do
whatever your genius ETL stuff was and
that's really frustrating and so based
on both of these true facts and also
while I was looking at some past PI data
talks to get an idea of you know what
people are talking about these types of
things I saw this quote which I totally
just wanted to steal and put my proposal
in the first place but instead I'm
attributing it here but I still want to
bring it up so I'm at PI data London
2016 this year there was this quote in
the beginning there was Kron we had one
job it ran at 1:00 a.m. and it was good
right and so Pete said it a little
differently later but basically what
happened for us as well as him is that
it wasn't just one job anymore it was
like a hundred jobs and it didn't run at
1 a.m. anymore it's like depends and
maybe if this other stuff ran
successfully then I want to run this
other thing and it was no longer good
and so we no longer were using cron and
said it was just chaos right so this was
kind of the situation that we found
ourselves in so the basic
here for us is that plumbing problem
suck this is true in real life and this
is also true for your data pipeline so
we knew that we had to figure something
else out so we already had some thoughts
about how we wanted this to go just
based on like our early proof of
concepts we would prefer something an
open-source Python so we know what's
going on and could easily extend it as
we're a Python shop at industry dive
we wanted something resilient this is a
lot about what I just sort of motivated
this talk about we wanted to handle
failure well any types of failure so we
wanted there to be retry logic able to
specify failure callbacks good alerting
and monitoring all this was going to
make our life a lot easier to figure out
what's going on we wanted it to be able
to deal with complexity intelligently so
we were growing and growing what we
wanted to do we needed more complicated
dependency parsing and we also wanted to
only have to run what it had to we
didn't want to have to do extra work if
we had already done some part of the
pipeline and we wanted a lot of
flexibility we wanted to be able to run
anything that we wanted and we already
knew that we had batch tasks that we
were planning on running on a daily and
hourly schedule so we were already just
in the in the market for a batch
processing system that could help us
deal with this so we traveled the land
and came up with this chart that I've
made to sort of squish down a lot of
different tools that we took a look at
and I kind of separate them into two
different classes we have these light
lighter color ones make Drake Pye do it
Luigi which I sort of discerned we're
more on the file based dependency system
so they look for certain files to change
or compare metadata between files and
then they do some sort of work that then
outputs to a file so all of the
dependency is based on which files where
have been made and when whereas these on
the other side and the darker gray
airflow AWS data pipeline in pinball we
found that those were more abstract
about their dependency generation it
wasn't tracked directly to files
necessarily and you would configure that
in code they all have their own sort of
way to represent that as we go across
this picture there's other sorts of
features that also become really great
besides these two sort of class
distinctions that also kind of vary
so we can start out where it's just a
dependency framework but as we go
further to the other side we'll see that
they'll ship with more scheduling we're
monitoring more alerting in the box to
sort of that point these ones on I guess
this is your left are more lightweight
they won't specify any sort of like
protocols you would normally use there's
not a lot of reusable components for
normal or I guess standard ETL type of
things but if you go to the other side
everything's a little more heavyweight
there's more infrastructure for it but
there's a lot more batteries included
and then there's also this x2 this
y-axis to mention about dachshund
community which was also really
important to us because we were
interested in being able to extend and
customize and you can see sort of my
take on how all of these different
things delivered it on that term as well
so first I'm just going to talk a little
bit about this file dependencies target
system concept so the concept for these
this class of pipelining tool is that
there's some files or file or files that
are some dependency that have to exist
before some sort of recipe or action has
to occur and that recipe or action will
consume those files somehow do something
and then output to some sort of target
and then the system will be able to tell
if this target exists we don't need to
redo that this recipe anymore or if
these files have changed like their
metadata their timestamp is different
from this target we know that there's
updated information here that we need to
filter into a new target
so make is like a classic example of
this and you can see here some of the
syntax
I'm not going to go into too many
details but that you can see the track
back to the file dependencies concept
what the target actually is and what
work we're actually going to do
Drake is sort of a extension to make
their tagline is like make for data
actually is what they call themselves so
this has a similar concept it started to
introduce more variable substitution
built in variable substitution and also
different types of protocols you didn't
just have to run bash scripts you could
give it other stuff that you wanted to
do and that's also growing for them as
well
PI do it is more of a Python version you
define all of your configuration and
your tests in Python code and
then this is the same sort of track back
you have a concept of targets a concept
of your file dependencies and the
concept of different actions that you
want to take on those and then Luigi is
another one that is sort of the bridge
between I think these two systems that
I'm talking about but it still has this
file dependency based design paradigm so
it will have a concept that a specific
test has some sort of requires method
that defines what files it depends on
some output method that defines where
the target output is going to be written
to and then the actual logic so well we
were taking a look at these tools we
came up with different pros and cons
pros we really liked that this work was
cached in these files for each of these
different steps especially we were
coming at it from we had a lot of
different transformations we wanted to
be able to do and we liked that if we
got so far in the process and something
came up
later it was easy for us to just start
again from wherever we left off and the
you saw the syntax really briefly here
but it's pretty simple and intuitive
configuration for data transformations
especially you have a inputs you have a
target and you do some work and the
syntax is really clear and simple cons
for us was that there wasn't really
native concept of things happening on
any sort of schedule so Luigi started to
introduce this but this concept doesn't
really exist outside of you building it
yourself and Luigi doesn't have an
actual polling process to figure out
when it needs to do stuff so that didn't
come included the alerting systems for
these felt a little too basic too much
like heavy lifting for us to rewrite
them to include them and the design
paradigm was not broadly applicable to
other non-target operations so if you
wanted to do something else that didn't
necessarily do this type that wasn't a
data transformation but you had other
types of stuff that you wanted to live
in the same ecosystem this didn't really
like naturally fall into that kind of
work so the other class are the darker
gray ones that I showed you on that
first image I have made up this term
called abstract orchestration systems to
define what they are but they're less
concerned with targets because these
tasks don't necessarily have to have
actual data transfer between them but
they do have some sort of logical
dependency that one has to happen before
the other one
and so you define these relationships
between these tasks by um and whatever
the code configuration system is for
these different platforms and then you
end up with this graph that shows you
your different types of work and what
their edges connecting them are so for
example one we looked at was pinball so
you can see it's getting like a little
more fancy here and the actual just work
here is specified this dependency and
this work is really specified right here
but all of these start to incorporate
the concept of things happening on a
schedule and also incorporate the
concept of a schedule of process that's
constantly checking to see if it's time
to do something this is air flow we'll
go into this a little bit more too but
this is what the configuration kind of
looks for that like for that so you have
this pythonic way to set these
relationships and the whole
configuration ends up in Python so when
we were taking a look at all these
abstract orchestration systems so we
liked that a lot of these there's a lot
of coincident features that also are
occurring like there's many more
operations supported out-of-the-box with
these types of systems they're just like
a little more sophisticated and there's
a lot more behind them they handle more
complicated dependency logic all sorts
of different types of trigger rolls
things can branch things could depend on
each other only sometimes they could
have all different types of schedules
and the scheduling process the
monitoring and the alerting services
that are already built in are pretty
sophisticated so you didn't need to have
a separate scheduling service to figure
out if it was time to do any work but
also there's just some monitoring
monitoring tools or especially email
alerting is a really popular one that
was already built in cons for us this
caching concept the Spile caching
concept kind of went away so the idea at
that individual data transformations
could cache their data in between was
not something that was really a native
concept anymore the configuration is
more complex you saw the code examples a
little bit it's no longer just two lines
to describe your targets your file
dependencies and your outputs and
there's more infrastructure so now
instead of the state of your work flow
pipeline existing in files on disk
instead there needs to be some other
person
storage that knows what's going on in
all of these cases they have some sort
of database back that is keeping track
of what has been worked on and what
hasn't and a lot of these also
especially airflow I'll talk about allow
for you to have a distributed system so
in this case you're scheduling process
and the actual stuff doing the work
needs to have some middle committal way
to communicate especially if those
workers are on different servers so then
you need to set up a messaging queue for
the actual distribution if you decide to
do that so it's a little more
heavyweight so after we thought about
all this stuff we had more opinions and
we decided that we liked the
sophistication of the abstract
orchestration systems we liked the
batteries included stuff all the stuff
that came in the box but we did also
like the Drake and make and Luigi esque
file targeting especially for our data
transformation steps that we were really
working on and it makes it easy to see
transparently what's going on to do this
file caching and also to do data bug
tracking you can easily see we went from
this to that
everything's cached and it's really easy
to take a look and we termed these
intermediate artifacts is sort of our
thought process of what these are this
this cache that we're building up we aka
me okay DevOps didn't want to maintain a
separate scheduling service I kind of
wanted this all to be kind of more
together and so that was another big
reason that I liked the abstract
orchestration systems we like a really
strong community and good documentation
I mentioned before we wanted to be able
to extend this was something that made
us of the three that I mentioned that
are abstract orchestration systems
pinball wasn't really like the
competitor in this kind of space they
didn't have a ton of great documentation
at least at the point that we were
taking a look at it so we didn't feel
like it was going to be really easy to
plug into the community and we also
didn't want to be stuck in one ecosystem
if you choose AWS data pipeline it's
like super AWS times if you're already
in a system that's using a lot of AWS
resources and all of your data is there
and moving around in AWS that makes a
ton of sense but for us it wasn't really
the case and we wanted to be able to
support a lot of differ
stuff so we weren't super hyped about
that either so we decided to go with
airflow and we also decided to pull in
the Spile caching system from the Drake
Luigi times into our maybe semi rudely
named personal library called smart
airflow and we thought that this was
awesome so here's a little more details
about airflow and the features that they
support so they have a scheduler process
that handles the actual triggering and
executing of the work you specify the
works in these files called DAGs short
for directed acyclic graph some of the
other other the other systems had more
fancy names they just went with dag it
is what it is
and they can the scheduler can trigger
these tags on a given schedule there's a
lot of built in a learning based on SL
azor the task states so if your task has
a failed state or a success state or if
it has a retry state or skip state
there's a whole pantheon of different
types of states they could have that you
could specify different types of
callbacks for and there's lots of sexy
profiling visualizations so they really
they really got it with the UI the way
to make it easy for you to track what's
going on see your task history they also
put in a lot of other stuff to the UI
like different levels of authentication
being able to tune permissions so you as
the dev ops person might take a look at
it but also all your analysts can take a
look at and you can control like what
they might want to be able to be in
charge of there is a really convenient
CLI that among being able to do many of
the things that the you that the web UI
can do it also has these particular
helpful things test backfill and clear
which I'll talk about some of these a
little bit later too but the seal it CLI
was just really built out the operators
come which is a type of tasks come from
a number of pre-built classes so they
have a Python operator like s3 key
sensor based transfer these are all
different things that you might want to
do and a lot of them already came in
there's lots of stuff to connect with MS
sequel with my sequel with Postgres
there's stuff to connect with hive to
start a spark job to start in a Duke job
all sorts of different stuff those
already built in submitted by the
airflow core committers or the
community so that was really exciting
too and you can obviously extend any of
them using inheritance and we liked that
it can support local work execution but
also distributed work execution so it's
a scalable system so if you want to use
distributed it uses the Python library
celery to communicate with a message
queue there's several that celery
support RabbitMQ and Redis or really
popular ones but this was a scalable
thing we knew we could use this later as
our test went way past 100 or 500 when
we needed lots of servers or lots of
different types of servers for example
so this is how the actual architecture
kind of works for air flow so air flow
itself the services that air flow ships
is the web server and then another
concept that's called the executor the
executor contains both the scheduler and
the worker processes there's different
types of executors there's ones where
both of these are done by the same
process there's ones where one of these
is the parent process and can spawn
other smaller processes child processes
or there's the case where you have the
scheduler in a totally separate process
and the workers are all on a different
server and a totally different process
not in the same space at all and then in
that case you need to use some sort of
queue to facilitate communication
between them and both the web server and
whichever executor you're you choose
also needs to have some metadata
database to keep state since we're no
longer keeping state in on disk on the
file and the file system I mean so this
is just the general architecture of how
your air flow setup will go so here are
some pretty pictures of this nice UI
that they spent nice time building so
this gives you an idea of how you can
interact with this or how different
people in your organization can interact
with your air flow instance to schedule
work or stop scheduling work or whatever
HAP what-have-you so you can have
different tags here you can notice what
their scheduler schedule is for you can
turn them on and off you can check what
the recent status is stuff that has
succeded stuff that has failed stuff
that is still running and you have
hotkeys to a bunch of other different
types of views into this data
some of which I'm gonna show you in fact
this was one of them
the graph view so this is a way to take
a look at a given dag and visualize what
all the nodes and edges of the different
types of tests and dependencies are so
you can look at this on a per day in the
abstract and also per day or per hour
whatever your schedule is so you can
take a look see a lot of the same stuff
in terms of different tasks stat I but I
see it in this type of view instead and
there's a bunch of other tabs of
different ways to look at things and I
especially really like and I'm going to
show you the Gantt chart and the tree
view oops so this is the tree view that
they create so since we have a concept
of a schedule schedule we have a concept
of a schedule or who's gonna do stuff
over and over we have historical data
about tasks that have happened in the
past so this is one visualization tool
that they have to take a look at all
your different tasks in the past and you
can also take a look at their status
change the base state so you can look
further in the past or however you like
and also trigger things from here if you
need to and the Gantt tool this is one
of just many monitoring tools that you
eyes that I found really useful to be
able to diagnose issues with my
different tags this is like your
standard Gantt chart you can see
different tasks and when they ran and
how long it took them and how they
overlapped with anything else and so
this can give you a view like maybe
something we're just going on here or
maybe there's a good reason that it took
this long and there's a lot of other
visualizations you can actually roll
your own visualizations too and add your
own views onto this if there's some sort
of specific situation you want to take a
look at for a specific dag and then you
can track that information and you can
always query the metadata database
there's actually a tool built into this
UI to do it from here or whatever it is
you can connect directly and take a look
at all this historical data and do
whatever profiling that you need so
let's talk about DAGs and tasks so this
is the abstract concept here airflows
implementation of this graph concept of
dependencies I mentioned that a dag is a
collection of things that have some sort
of connection to each other and those
things are tasks in air flow there's
sort of two different types of
there's sensors which are kind of like
event bindings they're pulling waiting
for some sort of situation to be true so
this is a case like s3 key sensor
waiting for a key to show up an s3
bucket or there's a bunch of other ones
and then operators once they are cleared
to start working because they're do
their tasks dependencies have been met
then they just execute whatever work
that they need to do maybe they need to
run a sequel script or maybe they need
to run some Python script or any sort of
type of thing and DAGs and tasks have
different types of properties you can
use to configure them so you can reuse
different types of desks tasks and reuse
different types of DAGs if you lake DAGs
have a concept of what their schedule
interval is which I'll get into some
more details about later this is how
often it needs to be scheduled tasks
have a bunch of properties that might be
shared between different kinds like who
owns them how many retries they should
try for maybe you don't want it to retry
at all maybe you wanted it to retry 10
times I don't know you can do that at
the task level so they're all very
specifically configurable you can give
each task its own failure callback if
there's some special case that you want
to happen if task B fails but you want
some other thing to happen at C fails
then you can do stuff like that and then
they there's tons of other ones this is
certainly not a complete list so this is
an idea of the configuration I showed
you a little bit before really quickly
but you can specify a dag here's the dag
definition that takes its parameters and
then different tasks that can be a
different operator or sensor types and
then down here on line 44 this is where
we're actually specifying the
connections between them so I'm setting
the T to task the t1 task upstream of
the t2 task and so this is just your
basic configuration how you actually
would specify this in code so since we
have this concept of time which I keep
elite alluding to let's talk about dag
runs and tasks instances sodags and
tasks are an abstract concept but dag
runs actually our DAGs at a certain time
there DAGs that represent some period of
time
tasks instances are the tests that
belonged to that dag run so they inherit
inherit the concept of time from their
dag run and you can really see this in
this tree view each of these columns and
these circles represent some type of dag
run that happened for some certain time
and all these little boxes are all the
task instances that were part of that
dag run that were scheduled for the same
time that that dagger run was active so
a little bit more about the architecture
and how this actually works the the
connection between the executors the
webserver your metadata database and
whatever your cue is if you decide to
use a cue and then the actual dag
definition files those Python files that
specify the graph dependencies those
exist on file somewhere that you would
deploy with your airflow service so it
starts out where the scheduler pulls the
tags that are on disk and the metadata
database to figure out what it wants to
do so I can see from the DAGs what it's
supposed to do it can see from the
metadata database what's already
happened and so it can make some
decision about what it's time to do
right now so once it figures out and
starts freaking out that it's time to do
the thing it will especially if like at
industry dive you're using a messaging
queue to distribute the information from
the scheduler to the worker it's going
to submit that message to the queue that
says do the thing and then the scheduler
is also going to notify the metadata
database that it told the queue what was
going on and inside the metadata
database we'll have an entry for a dag
run that knows that it's running and an
entry for a task instance associated
with that dag run that knows that it's
queued that it's waiting to work so okay
also the worker is going to be pulling
into this queue to figure out what it's
supposed to do and once it sees that
there's a message in the queue it's
going to get all excited and decide to
do that and it's going to communicate to
both the queue and the metadata database
okay I got the message I'm on it so the
queue now knows that this message is
being worked on and the metadata
database also knows that this test
instance is being worked on yes
yeah so thus get the the dad
configuration specifies that the
scheduler is in charge of killing
anything that it needs to kill
so that's interesting question there's
different ways that you can specify what
your timeouts are you could not have one
I guess if you really wanted to another
popular thing is to use SL A's which
alert don't actually kill the process
but alert you in some other way that
something has gone wrong I expected this
to take less than two hours but it's
been two hours in one second and I don't
know what's happening and then you can
take an intervention action so if you
had like a really weird case where you
didn't know what was going on you could
use that instead okay so the worker has
communicated to everybody that
something's being done so eventually the
worker will act back to the cue that it
has succeeded and also till the metadata
database that it has succeeded on this
task instance that it worked on so now
the metadata database knows that the
task instance is done so the cue this is
sort of like ephemeral messaging storage
here so eventually the queues like okay
I did my job by data but the good thing
is that we have this metadata database
over here that still knows all this
history still knows what has been
completed and because of this the
scheduler can again keep doing this
process ask check the dag files check
the metadata database to figure out
what's going on and perhaps in this case
our dag only specifies this one task
instance so if this task is done the
whole dag is done so the scheduler can
update the metadata database at that
point and decide that ok we're done with
that one and update this metadata world
for everybody and since we've got this
webserver and the people love you eyes
he's got to put some data on it so since
we have this persistent store over here
with all of this data about what's been
going on the webserver can now show that
to everybody so that's the basic idea of
how everything is communicating here so
alerting is fun this is something that
we like so we talked just a little bit
about SL A's you can use these to set up
sort of a maximum boundary before you
think something weird is going on and
then you can take a human intervention
you can specify different callbacks or
you can also already built-in is email
on retry failure success or any other
types of things so if you're cool with
the official like airflow template for
how emails get sent to you on these
different types of things maybe you
don't need any sort of special callback
you can specify whatever different
timeouts that you need based on what how
long you expect stuff to work and
there's also other ways to connect with
other services that you might use for
alerting so there already is in airflow
course lack operator so if you use slack
at your work you can easily communicate
with that but you could do this to make
one for like Pedro duty or jet or
whatever it is that you use
configuration abounds so we have a
concept of pools which I'll talk about a
little bit later and queues which is a
way to manage your workers manage your
resources so that you don't necessarily
want all hundred possible tests that
could be allowed right now to hit your
database at the same time but if you
have a bunch of other stuff that can run
in parallel without too much confusion
you might let them use a bigger pool or
a bigger queue and I mentioned you can
turn your DAGs on and off and you can
also specify different levels of retries
at the tasks level so that's really nice
as well and there's lots of flexibility
we have tons of different types of
operators that are already built in and
the other great thing is that you can
extend your own which leaves me a little
bit - what we decided to do which was to
add in this concept of smart air flow
which borrowed this file dependencies
concept that we liked from the other
other tools and brought it into air flow
so air flow itself doesn't support much
data transfer only small pieces of data
via this thing called XCOM but it's like
a string or an integer it's not like
your whole whatever you were working on
so we added this plugin to air flow that
supports local file system or s3 backed
intermediate artifact storage and it
basically leverages air flow concepts to
make that file location' predictable so
that if you do have this dependency you
have an edge between two tasks it can
easily go figure out where its upstream
task data is automatically by using this
plugin so this is just some Doc's about
it but the important thing is it knows
how to get the input file name and get
the output file name for itself
and it knows how to predict all of that
and then so you don't have to deal with
figuring out where those files are
yourself or configure it during the dag
so this led us to an ETL paradigm where
we wanted to make each task as small as
possible while maintaining readability
because this could get out of hand
I'm sure you could imagine so still
maintaining readability
and we would preserve the output for
each task in the file based intermediate
artifacts so we wanted in a format that
was consumable by its dependent tasks so
this is the whole file cache and we
wanted to avoid finalizing our artifacts
for as long as possible we're doing the
state of warehousing thing eventually we
have to do the L in ETL but we're
waiting until we've completed all these
smaller tasks so we can confirm that all
of the work was done that we the way we
wanted to we can go back to the cache if
we needed to and then we finalize
whatever it is as the last step and the
simplest step in the dag is storage so
if I've sold you on airflo you don't
actually have to throw any money at it
because it is free and open source and
you can actually it's on pi PI so you
can pip install air flow to get started
really quick and they've made it really
easy to get started in like 30 seconds
right there's like a built-in Kampai
that already knows some sensible
defaults it will spin up a sequel light
metadata database that already came with
your Python distribution there's a ton
of example tags so you can just get it
started if you want to move up to
something a little more productionize
for us a github username Puckle created
a docker airflow repository that has
docker files and docker compose files
about setting this up more production
level scale so we've extended from
there's for our specific use case but I
really recommend that and also in the
repository at Apache Incubator air flow
there are some upstart and some systemd
templates that the community has
contributed as well if you don't want to
use docker so some things some tips
tricks and gotchas for air flow that I
have learned minimize your dev
environment with the easier executors
you don't necessarily need to use your
celery executors right out of the box so
you can separate your logic problems
from your system problems and there's a
CLI called airflow test that also makes
it really easy to just run things in the
foreground without interacting with the
metadata database if you just need to do
a quick test when you do get to the
point where you you want to test your
dag with the scheduler there's this
handy dandy at once scheduled interval
so the schedule will just pick up
knowing that it's time to run something
immediately you don't have to put it on
some schedule and then like wait 5
minutes or 10 minutes or anything like
that you can just use this at once and
it will just immediately try and start
to execute
my tip don't bother with the nascent
plug-in system air flow does have a
plug-in system but it's on the roadmap
to improve it but it's most people just
ship their custom operators with their
DAGs through whatever deployment process
they have they don't try and like build
a airflow plug-in separately and another
thing that kind of surprises some people
or surprised us for sure there's no
built in log rotation and it the air
flow service automatically like stores
all its log files to disk in this kind
of complicated location and the default
logging is really verbose and then if
you add in your own it starts to get
really large so as of air flow 1.7
there's a really simple thing in coughed
up high you can configure for it to
actually just send all those logs to s3
and then you can just set up whatever
you want to just clear out all of the
local logs as you see fit for us we have
about 1300 tasks across eight active
DAGs and 27 worker processes that are
all sitting on the same m4 extra-large
AWS ec2 instance so we utilize pools I
mentioned a little bit before to manage
resources so we have like a lot of
storage tests but we don't want them all
like trying to communicate to the
database at once so we create a pool
that only has one or two workers
subscribe to it and then that's where
all of our database tasks go you should
consider using queues if you have really
different types of work to do so if you
need like an AR server and you need a go
server and a scala server or whatever
you can set up a distributed system and
then use the queues instead to have
workers only subscribe to certain types
of queues and have the scheduler only
submit certain types of work to those
queues and we're using retries here so
if it wasn't clear your tests need to be
it input I didn't potent if you are
going to be using that so that they can
you don't get surprised if they run
again so last thing the biggest gotcha
that happens for users for air flow is
this time concept like when this stuff
happening and when is my schedule going
so here's a line that is time and you
can and we as humans do split up time
into arbitrary intervals and for example
it might be every 24 hours and in the
air flow speak this is a scheduled
interval the scheduled intervals are
represented by their execution date
which is at the top of the scheduled
interval so this entire period of time
here is represented by this execution
date that's at the top of the interval
so here's like the Guitar Hero period so
data is like streaming in and time time
is moving on and sometimes we cross
these arbitrary boundaries and we get
more data bla bla bla
so for at the situation where now is
here we can't actually do the work for
the execution date for the schedule
interval that the top of it is
represented by 2016 1001 until this
allowable time so once we get to
execution date + schedule interval it's
now allowable so all the data has
already by the time we get to here all
the data that represents 2016 1001 has
already happened right all the data that
could possibly come for that date is
done so the actual time that the dag run
gets instantiated is after this
allowable date this dag run gets
associated with this execution date but
it has a concept called
start date which is when it actually
started right the actual time that the
run happened is different from the data
that it's representing and this like
blows people's minds right because it it
doesn't necessarily make sense and also
these words are maybe not the best words
to represent them and everybody's
everyday usage so execution date does
not equal start date and it's the same
for tasks instances - since they inherit
their configuration from the dag runs
you can kind of see here but this run
was scheduled for 2016 1008 at 4:00 UTC
but it didn't actually start until 2016
10 oh 7 at 4 and 23 seconds UTC and
possibly the most confusing thing ever
is that execution date does not equal
start date but sometimes start date
doesn't equal start date because in the
dag model there's another keyword
argument called start date that is
unrelated completely to this concept of
execution date and start date that is
relevant for dag runs and tasks
instances so this is also in the roadmap
to come to clear up this confusion but a
lot of people get confused about this
issue so um I just wanted to point out
that there's another term there's
another column in the metadata database
somewhere else called start date that
doesn't mean the same thing if you still
don't get it and are very confused I
definitely recommend gotta make a time
travel dude time travel yourself
if we're in the future right now and
you're watching this online rewind and
if we're in the future either now these
people here in real time or the people
on video ask me I'm pretty friendly I
gave you all my internet communication
ways so feel free to ask me and actually
this conversation has been going on with
air flow on the Google Groups
on the Gitter and air flow Docs on the
dev mislay list on the devilís mailing
archives there's a lot to look at and
I'm saying that kind of tongue-in-cheek
here I kind of want to point that out
because they have a really great
community and a lot of people who are
are trying to use this and trying to
figure it out so there's a lot of great
information there in fact there as I as
I kind of alluded to but didn't
explicitly mention they are an
incubating project for Apache so they
were one day be Apache airflow they
originally came from Airbnb and they're
hardening their first Apache release
right now actually so if you wanted to
get into thick of things right now
before it's cool now's the time so
that's it I did want to say PS there's
an appendix and the longer version of
this talk I included way more details
about all those other pipelining things
that I didn't talk about so if you get
these slides online I've submitted them
to wherever in the ether to PI data that
someday they will show up somewhere then
you can keep scrolling through if you
want to get some more details about
those but otherwise that's it for this
and I'm happy to take any questions yes
hmm
yes and some people so DAGs are can our
Python files and so you can import them
around you can create tags dynamically
you could have some sort of for loop
that iterates over some type of
condition that your dag is testing for
to decide if it needs to make more tags
we use that at the tasks level so inside
a dag we query for this like list of
different types of data that we want to
work on and then we dynamically
instantiate all of our tasks so you can
do stuff like that so the way that that
interacts with the scheduler the
scheduler is pulling the files every 5
seconds or you can configure that you
can make it different is pulling the
files every 5 seconds so if you have
some sort of like dynamic situation that
is changing externally then the
scheduler can keep picking it up it's
going to keep pulling those files it
doesn't like hold them in memory so if
some external situation changes then it
the scheduler will pick that up
and then decide to do that work the dag
configuration is file based so
so the scheduler knows what work should
be done in what order based on these
files and then it pulls it it builds its
own sort of idea of the graph and
compares it to the metadata database and
then sends those message to the workers
or the worker queue and then the worker
just picks them up so the scheduler is
in charge of figuring out what needs to
happen based on whatever this template
is of what is supposed to happen and
what it already knew did happen does
that make sense
okay yes right that's a good question
and when I'm not really prepared to
answer because I had that requirement
from the beginning I do know that there
are some like commercial products to I
guess AWS data pipeline is kind of a
commercial product but a lot of people
compare this to Uzis and azkaban or I
don't I don't actually know what they're
called because I haven't used them but
some people use those tools as well it's
actually in the air flow Docs they're
like we're comparable to you blah blah
but like we're Python open source free
blah blah blah so I can't really answer
your question in other terms but that's
some other stuff that I've seen yes
right there right
sure the question was about what I've
had to overcome with airflow so
definitely the shortlist was kind of all
those things I mentioned the start date
drama was the biggest drama of them all
I would say and as you mentioned the
airflow we've been using it for the past
year we started on 1/6 now they're on
1/7 and there was a bunch of sort of
weird stuff going on then like they had
a problem where a couple bugs where the
scheduler you had to like bounce it
every once in a while because we're like
randomly hang which has been resolved
and we have never actually observed
since we've moved up to 1/7 but stuff
like that that was kind of surprising
but other than that I think basically
that list what I feel is all that we've
really experienced so it's you want to
talk about whatever your thing was we
can talk about it sometime yeah no
problem
yes
sure so if your job requires rollback in
case they that you fail so that is the
purview of the task to define so if it
would need to define however it needs to
rollback you could include that for
example in on failure callback for that
task if it does some sort of if it
throws some sort of weird exception you
could have it rollback based on whatever
logic you define and its callback or it
sort of depends what you're doing if
you're doing some sort of data database
stuff you could wrap the whole thing in
transaction if it throws an exception
then the whole the database is going to
roll back roll it back for you so that
it's mostly in the purview of the logic
that you write so is the answer that
make sense yeah anything else all right
well you can definitely contact me on
the internet anyway and I'll be hanging
around PI data for the rest of the time
so thank you very much